When I was a young boy...
when I was young, I considered them,
considered those issues, as sensational.
And as a matter of fact, there
are about four or five issues
about which the Rishonim disagree.
And those issues I would like simply
to point those issues out to you
and discuss them just for a short time.
It would not take long.
In general, Sefiras HaOmer, there
are, I would say four issues in
Sefiras HaOmer, as I said before,
which are almost sensational.
Do you know of
machlokes with regard to Sefiras HaOmer?
Central, basic machlokes.
...controversies with
regard to Sefiras HaOmer.
Basic, I don't mean peripheral machlokes.
There are many machlokes peripheral.
What?
[Answer from Audience -- One
mitzvah, 49 mitzvos?] 49?
What?
[Answer from Audience -- One
complete mitzvah one mitzvah or
each night is a mitzvah...] No.
This to me no issue.
This to me no issue,
because it is no issue.
No.
I say, and that's ... chakirah...
already abstraction here.
Simply halacha lemaaseh Rishonim disagree,
I mean about, but I would say four issues.
Four controversies.
What?
[Answer from Audience -- Deoraysa,
derabanan.] Correct.
Correct, correct.
The mitzvah itself bizman hazeh,
is it mideoraysa or miderabanan?
Fine.
We will return to this problem.
Next.
What would you suggest next?
Audience -- Weeks or days?] Huh?
What, what?
[Answer from Audience.]
Yomim or whether
shavuos should be included in the yomim.
What is the machlokes haRishonim if there
is a machlokes, of course a machlokes?
What does the machlokes consist of?
With regard to what?
With regard to the nusach,
to the text of sefirah.
One opinion is the text of sefirah should
be read, I mean should be found in the,
the sefirah should be, the way we do,
this is the proper, the proper method.
What is our minhag?
What is our practice?
[Answer from Audience -- Yomim and shvuos.]
Now yomim and shvuos is ... Rishonim,
there's a machlokes, I
mean the Gemara Ameimar.
Yomim ushvuos, if we are speaking about
yomim ushvuos in general, you have a
machlokes in the Gemara Ameimar ... Devei
Rav Ashi, Rav Ashi and Ameimar.
The machlokes in the Gemara whether
there is a mitzvah shvuos bizman hazeh.
But in the Gemara, the question is if
So what do you do?
Do you have to mention
shavuos every night?
Or once in seven days?
The mitzvah lememnei yomei,
mitzvah lememnei shvuei.
Minyan shvuei is a mitzvah which
is binding throughout the period of
sefirah, because if mitzvah lememnei
shvuei is not only the weeks,
even the yomim, for instance, you had
to say, let us take from yesterday, or
before yesterday, say, Hayom araba'a
asar yom shehem shnei shavuos ba'omer.
This is according to everybody you have
got, because, I have got to mention
it, because if we pass mitzvah lememnei
yomei mitzvah lememnei shvuei, the
shvuei means, what does shavua mean?
Every night?
Or shavua means every night on which
the week is completed, completed.
There are, our minhag is that the
mitzvah shvuei applies not only to whole
weeks, but fractional weeks as well.
... what we asked last night, was
sheheim chamisha asar yom.
So I have to repeat, sheheim
shnei shavuos, sheheim
shnei shavuos veyom echad.
Or shnei yomim or shlosha yomim.
Is the integration of
the week out of the yomim
is also a part of minyan hashavuos.
Minyan hashavuos is not only when you have
entities, when you have separate entities,
but minyan hashavuos is even if one, if
the end the shavuos are, for instance
shavuos you have three days, three days,
I have three shavuos and five
days ba'omer, is also the mitzvah.
The mitzvah is the process of integration.
I mean, of counting up to seven
and integrate the seven, and
we'll start with 14 and so forth.
This according to most Rishonim, many
Rishonim, not most of them, many Rishonim
is as long as the shavua is not
complete, it's not mentioned.
If for instance, I mention only
hayom, hayom shlosha shavuos ba'omer.
It means at the end of the shavua, means
the seventh, the fourteenth, twenty-first,
the twenty-eighth, and so forth.
When I obtain a shavua,
a total shavua I mean.
Fractions, I mean, don't count.
This a machlokes haRishonim.
This was quite a,
you can simply divide the
Rishonim into two groups.
So, many Rishonim require the
mention of shavuos every night.
Many Rishonim say every night
makes no sense...the mention of
shavuos at the conclusion of the
week, of the days.
[Comment from Audience -- Multiples
of seven.] What you say?
of seven.] Yes, sure ... sure.
Now.
One.
What is next?
Interesting is, interesting is, no, no,
no, no, interesting is something else.
The Rambam in Sefer
Hamitzvos, the Rambam in Mishneh
Torah, we don't know anything.
The shavuos, I mean is very short
and very brief, it's very hard
to get to some conclusions as
far as the controversy is concerned.
But the Rambam, the Rambam
in explaining, in explaining
his method as far as minyan hamitzvos
is concerned,
the question was, the
question which rose before the Rambam
is whether to count shavuos and yomim
as two mitzvos, or count yomim as one
mitzva which includes shavuos as well.
The Rambam has in Sefer Hamitzvos.
So the Rambam says no, shavuos should
not be counted as separate mitzvah,
shouldn't be counted as separate mitzvah.
Shavuos should be counted as, while
yomim ushvuos are one mitzvah.
Because it's not a mitzvah for
two minyanim, but the mitzvah is
to count yomim and organize them into
units, and each unit is
what? Is the shavua.
It means when I count Hayom ... arba'a
asar yom sheheim shnei shavuos
ba'omer, I shouldn't look upon this
as a separate count, ... shnei yomim
and then arba'a
asar yom and then acount of shnei shavuos.
The shnei shavuos is actually
included in the minyan hayomim.
I have got to count yomim and
then immediately organize the
yomim into units of shavuos.
But shavua is a prat, so to
say ..., it is an expression
actually of the minyan hayomim.
Interesting is that
actually in the Torah,
is the shavua emphasized.
Shiva shavuos tispor lach
mehachel chermeish bakomoh
tachel lispor shiva shavuos.
Shiva shavuos tispor lach.
And then Chag Shavuos.
But the Rambam was
almost insists, apparently, but the
But the Rambam considers the minyan hayomimas the main,
as the most important
minyan, while shavuos is just a
qualification in minyan hayomim.
You see, I can count a dollar.
I count a dollar, the way it
is integrated from pennies.
But it is not,
the minyan of the pennies
includes, then when I get to the dollar,
so the pennies are organized into units,
into entities, but there is only a
kiyum of yomim, not a kiyum of shavuos.
How does the Rambam know that?
He says ... our minhag is to, and the
Rambam, the following controversy, whether
the minyan of Omer
is consists of
yomim, whether minyan haOmer, this
controversy, should every night I have
got to mention the minyan hashavuos,
or minyan hashavuos enough for me
that I mention it once a week, is this
depends upon the problem whether yomim
ushvuos are one mitzvah or two mitzvos.
Because if there are two
mitzvos, you have got
to mention the shavua every
night, that's exactly what we do.
But however, if it is one mitzvah,
yomim is just a qualification I mean
... shavua is a qualification as far as
yomim are concerned.
And if it's a qualification it's
only at the end of the shavua,
not in the middle of the shavua.
You have, no one has [inaudible].
But actually
we don't understand the Rambam.
What is the proof?
It might be for instance we mention
shavuos every night, it's our minhag,
but we might agree with all the
opinions, with the opinions of the
Rishonim, that the mitzvah is not
shavuos and the mitzvah is yomim.
And then the Rambam says something else.
Had the mitzvah been shavuos as
well as yomim, you would say,
you would count Omer, you would
count Omer with two brachos.
Limnos chamishim yom
and minyan shiva shavuos.
The fact that we don't count yomim
and shvuos with two brachos, but
with one bracha, is apparently
that the kiyum hamitzvah consists
exclusively in the yomim.
The shavuos is just
a kiyum in the yomim.
The yom should not be left just 45 days.
If you count 45 days, you
have to explain, I mean,
what do 45 days mean in term of shavuos.
The next unit is shavua to yomim.
This is, this is the Rambam.
Now next, what's next?
Huh?
[Answer from audience.] I don't hear you.
You mean the Tosfos that Sefiras
HaOmer is good before bein hashmashos,
not only good, but Tosfos recommends that
it be counted before bein hashmashos.
Not only it's good, ... mitzvah,
that's because of temimos.
Nu, and many Rishonim disagree,
many Rishonim say that, that
Sefiras HaOmer requires laylah.
Bein hashmashos
is not good enough;
we need laylah.
I mean, our minhag is to wait
on days on which we count
sefirah for tzeis hakochavim,
not to count sefirah immediately
with shkias hachamah.
Alright, why does Tosfos say?
Because it is temimos.
Temimos.
Tosfos [inaudible] is kasher
bein hashmashos, [Inaudible]
we always knew that if he
counts before bein hashmashos, the
counting during bein hashmashos,
then to postpone it until after
bein hashmashos because of temimos.
Is this,
what did Tosfos understand by temimos?
For instance, the problem of, the
Halachos Gedolos' problem, shochach,
he forgot, there I understand what
temimos means, because if I skipped
one sefirah is there is no minyan.
Sefirah is a series,
[inaudible] sefirah.
And if I cannot get, if I have
lost the third day, I cannot get
from the second to the fourth.
This is temimos, temimos in the
maaseh sefirah, temimos we understand.
It is that the minyan be a tamim, the
minyan be a continuously total minyan.
That I understand.
But Tosfos'
temimos is a different kind of temimos.
It's not in the minyan, the
minyan is correct anyway.
I count one, two, three,
four, five every night,
every night
I mean, bein hashmashos.
Is the minyan, the minyan
there is temimos in the minyan.
So what is Tosfos, how does Tosfos
utilize the bein hashmashos ... temimos
with regard to bein hashmashos?
Why is it not temimos?
You understand me?
Temimos means simple.
If I want to get to 49, I cannot get
to 49 unless all sfiros are counted.
Every day is counted with sefirah.
So gradually I get to the
sefirah of 49, the last sefirah.
That I understand.
But as I told you, in counting, if
you don't count 10, you counted 9,
you skipped 10, you want to count
11, so we'll tell him you're a liar,
because you yourself did not count 10.
It is 9 and 11.
You understand, that 9
and 11 is not a sefirah.
If it's not a sefirah, you cannot count
the sefirah... You need counting.
If I count 10 dollars, I want all the
10 dollars be placed on the table in
my, I could account for the 10 dollars.
So then it is sefirah.
But if I cannot account for the 10
dollars, I can account for 8 and 1, the 9
is missing, is not sefirah, then wonderful.
But this is not Tosfos.
Therefore I have got to
count bein hashmashos?
Why, therefore I have to
Huh?
[Answer from audience]
What do you mean each one?
Huh?
[Answers from audience] Yeah.
[Answers from audience] Not
zerizin makdimin lemitzvos,
not zerizim makdimin lemitzvos.
Zerizim makdimin lemitzvos
is a different thought.
I don't say zerizim makdimin
lemitzvos are not involved.
It's a different thought.
Be'emes, the Gemara [inaudible] Tosfos.
The Gemara says, yachol
yiktzor balaylah veyavi beyom.
The Gemara
Apparently it's very hard even
to express, to define that
the day should be, is
supposed to be counted.
The whole day has got to be counted.
The day has got to be a manuy.
In Rambam also, the Rambam
says, vesofrim balaylah.
Vesofrim balaylah.
Ve'im lo safar balaylah
vesafar beyom ... yatza.
The sofer balaylah, this is
not in the maaseh sefirah.
This is in the, I cannot
actually formulate it,
but it is in the chalos shem that
the 49 days from Shavuos to, from
Pesach to Shavuos should be menuyim.
And the earlier, the better.
The earlier is better.
...it is balaylah who needs bayom.
This is the Gemara.
But the Tosfos says, even balaylah itself,
you can push it up to bein hashmashos,
is certainly good.
That there is halacha of temimos,
not only with regard to the maaseh
sefirah, but there is a halacha of
temimos also with regard to the chalos
shem yom manuy yom menuy,
this is the Gemara.
The difference between the Tosfos
and the Gemara is, consists in what?
The difference.
The Gemara says it, and therefore
one should not wait with Sefiras
HaOmer until the night, until
the day, but he has got to count
immediately, I mean, during the time
of, during the night, he
has got to, not to wait.
...yachol yiktzor bayom veyimneh balaylah?
The Gemara temimos
beinan veleka.
And if he'll count when?
The day, there is no temimos.
Because what will be missing?
[Answer from audience] The part
of the yom, namely, the laylah.
Correct.
It will be missing.
That's what the Gemara says.
Tosfos says, the same logic,
Tosfos says, you can extend it.
Haschalas halaylah rather than in
the morning hours.
If I can count sefirah today,
...8:00, after 7:00, or 7:00,
as soon as possible, even bein
hashmashos, this is more temimos.
Somehow, the kiyum from temimos is
achieved
in ... almost a perfect manner
Namely, I include the
night and the day in what?
The night and the day in the 49 days,
in the menuyim, in the yomim menuyim.
You can argue with the Baalei HaTosfos.
[Comments from audience]
Again?
You may argue with the Baalei HaTosfos.
Please.
[Question from audience.] Just a moment,
it's a good question that you have.
I may disagree with the Baalei
HaTosfos and say laylah vayom is
two different zmanim, two different
entities of time, time entities.
There is laylah and yom.
And the sefirah has got to
include those two entities.
So that's why you cannot
postpone the sefirah
until dawn until amud hashachar,
but you have to count at night, but
when you count at night, there is
no difference whether you count at
haschalas halaylah or you count not
at haschalas halaylah but you count
betzeis halayah at the end of the night.
If the night is missing,
then it's not temimos.
But if the night is not missing,
not missing at all,
he'll count at night, but the night for
him will consist of the five last hours,
he'll count sefirah
at 4:00 in the morning, but the
sefirah will consist of both
zmanim, namely what?
[The audience answers -- Laylah
and yom.] This itself is enough.
Take a look at Rambam.
Take a look at Rambam, the Rambam says.
You have a Rambam?
Somebody have a... [Audience
member reads the Rambam]
...Mitchilas hayomim monin.
It is at the beginning of
the day that you have to count sefirah.
This is the halacha from temimos.
And therefore I do count at
night not in the daytime.
The night with regard to sefirah, the fact
that we have to
count at night is not because
sefirah is a mitzvah mierev balaylah.
But for a different reason.
Namely, what reason?
Because it's temimos.
When do I lose temimos?
When do I succeed in achieving temimos?
If the
sefirah takes place balaylah
regardless as to the hour, but
there are five minutes before amud
hashachar I can still count sefirah,
and actually and have a
sefirah consisting of temimos.
However if I counted
sefirah after the night has passed, then
there is no sefirah because the cheilek
hayom which we call laylah is missing.
That's what you have to say.
But anyway it's a machlokes haRishonim.
What's next?
I can't hear.
Shomea ke’oneh?
It was raised by the Rashba and the Magen
Avraham quotes him, but I don't believe
it was a very publicized controversy.
What?
[Answer from audience.] ...I don't
know about the controversy about...
oh, you mean the Ramban's shitah that,
Ramban's shitah as Friday you count,
you, oh, the Rashi shitah at night.
Rashi doesn't say it actually.
The [inaudible] explains the
Rashi's shitah, but you cannot,
we don't know exactly what Rashi says.
Rashi says Rashi went into beis
medrash and they were in the process
of counting sefirah, so Rashi counted
sefirah with them with a bracha.
Because Rashi's shitah
is that it was that you
may count sefirah bein hashmashos, this
in itself wouldn't have been a sensation.
But Rashi explained, if I should remind
myself too late in the night, that I
did not count sefirah bizmano, in its
proper time, so I'll repeat the count.
And if
I will not, I will forget to count
sefirah later at night before I
retire, I'll accomplish at least,
I'll accomplish the what, what
will I accomplish if I want to,
that mikol makom lo yafsid minyano,
I will not lose the minyan.
It means according to Rashi like that.
Sefirah requires shkiyas
hachama, bein hashmashos.
But this is only with regard
to the fulfillment of my duty.
Namely, that the mitzvah Sefiras
HaOmer, ... he counted with the minyan,
with the tzibbur, without a bracha.
He counted with the tzibbur, counted
with the tzibbur without a bracha.
Just a moment, how did Rashi say it?
[Answers from audience.]
Rashi did not say at night.
Night was my pshat.
[Comments from audience.] He
counts [answers from audience.]
Alright, in the first time without a
bracha... Yes, the second time I know.
According to Rashi,
the way Rashi is like this: haya
nichnas im hatzibbur, vehaya
moneh im hatzibbur belo bracha.
And later he used to repeat this
sefirah before retiring, before
retiring, but later, before
retiring, he made the bracha... So,
why did he count the sefirah prior to
that with the tzibbur?
What will he accomplish?
He says like that
in case I should forget,
I would not lose my count.
That’s Rashi.
So the Rishonim ask, ma nafshach?
If he counts later before retiring,
he counts without a bracha, ... the
second time with a bracha.
Yes.
The second time with a bracha.
The first time without a bracha.
So why does he say that it
will help him to protect him
against losing, losing the
entire mitzva of sefirah?
If he made a bracha the second
time, apparently the sefirah
the first time is not good.
If the sefirah is not valid
the first time, he should lose
the possibility, he should lose
the opportunity of sefirah
the second time if he forgot to
repeat, even though the bracha,
...even though he counted sefira
with the tzibbur, correct?
Yeah.
I'll discuss it.
I didn't have it in mind, this.
Pashut!
The machlokes the Behag and the
Rabbeinu Tam if he has forgotten
one day whether he continues to
count with a bracha or he has got to
discontinue the count with a bracha.
I mean the famous shittas Rabbeinu
Tam, the famous shittas Rabbeinu Tam,
I mean of Behag, hashochach
v'lo safar paam echas, harei ze sofer
beli ... bracha ... eino sofer klal.
This is a big machlokes between the
Rabbeinu Tam and the Behag
whether shochach v'lo safar balaylah,
shochach v'lo safar, whether he may
continue to count with a bracha or not.
What else? [Answer from audience.]
Yeah, but it's not a public machlokes.
This is the Rashba in the name
of other Rishonim.
Then ... shochach v'lo safar
balaylah what's about whether
he may say a bracha bayom?
If I did forget to count, is a
machlokes again, the Rabbeinu Tam
says that I cannot count with a bracha
because the laylah is not zman Sefiras Haomer.
The yom is not zman sefirah.
But many Rishonim, the
Rambam, shochach velo
mana balaylah, moneh bayom b'ivracha.
...the Rambam's shitah, moneh
bayom, bayom, when the Rambam says
moneh bayom means with a bracha.
Those are the basic controversies.
Yes.
So let's take one by one.
The controversy whether there is
minyan hashavuos, whether there is
minyan hashavuos every night, or minyan hashavuos
is limited only to
to the night on which the shavua, the
sefirah is completed, as far as the shavua
is concerned, every, yeah, multiples.
this is the machlokes haRishonim exactly.
The Tur quotes, the Tur, the
Chinuch ... This is number one.
Next is the machlokes, whether what?
Deroaysa derabanan.
The Rambam's shitah sefirah
bizman hazeh is what?
Deoraysa.
All the Rishonim, the
gemara, Ameimar mana yomei
velo mana shvuei amar zecher lemikdash.
Zecher lemikdash.
Is the gemara I mean apparently
considers mitzvas sefirah bezman
hazeh a derabanan, derabanan.
And then the two problems, whether sefirah
bayom is kasher, and the second problem is
whether in case of forgetting this
sefirah, whether he may continue
with the minyan or he cannot continue
with the minyan, with the tzibbur.
This is again a machlokes haRishonim.
Now the, let me say the following.
When the Behag says, you see, when
the mechaber says, shochach velo
mana balaylah moneh bayom beli
bracha, when I say it, it's correct.
I'll say shochach,
if I forgot to count the sefirah
at night, and I counted in
the daytime, I don't say a bracha.
Why don't I say a bracha, why?
[Answer from audience
-- Chaser the laylah.
So don't count at all?
Don't count at all.
[Answer from audience -- Legabei
temimos it counts.]
The answer is, when he says
it it's all right,
because when he say it, what does
it express belo bracha?
We don't know the halacha.
Since we don't know the halacha, we
know two Rishonim have disagreed,
namely the Behag and Rabbeinu Tam,
or the Rambam and the Rabbeinu Tam,
whether sefirah is valid in the daytime.
So in such a machlokes, in such a
case which Rishonim have, I mean,
have argued with each other and
their opinions are diametrically
opposed to each other, so he is
moneh belo bracha, like all sfeikos.
A sfeika d'oraysa
l'chumra, what do you do?
You are moneh belo bracha.
But the Behag cannot say that.
The Behag cannot say, lo mana
balaylah moneh bayom belo bracha.
It will be ridiculous.
You ask the Behag, I mean to tell
us the following, what is it?
Is the yom kosher lisfiras haomer or the yom I mean the sefirah bayom is not valid?
Unless the Behag will say he doesn't know,
so we'll say belo bracha.
But I hope the Behag
wouldn't say he doesn't know.
So it means the Behag will
say it's good, bayom is good.
If bayom is good, why not a bracha?
We have a text, which, shochach
velo mana balaylah, moneh bayom, you
cannot say belo bracha, [inaudible].
So not a question of a
Behag is not a question of two shittos
in Mishnah Berurah, you understand?
The Behag said moneh bayom,
he couldn't say bracha.
Either moneh bayom or eino moneh bayom.
Brachos is completely, the
Ramban cannot say ...
the mitzva and he,
without a bracha.
Why without a bracha?
Unless the Behag will say that he has a safek, he has a doubt in mind.
Very difficult. Yeah.
Tosfos in Megillah does have
the phrase, "Kosav HaBehag,
veheicha delo mana balaya,
moneh bayom belo bracha.
...the Gemara in Megillah you can find it.
Tosfos in Megillah quote,
might be, it might
have been a shigra d'lishna.
A shigrah d'lishna.
Because Tosfos in such cases he is
used to the expression belo bracha.
...kosav Behag
...It's a shigra d'lishna.
But anyway Tosfos should
have said, veheicha
delo mana balaylah moneh
bayom, kosav Behag.
So somehow it's a shigra d'lishna
or it's a taus sofer, I don't know.
But if one should be obstinate, be very
stubborn, and point out the text in
Tosfos, moneh bayom belo bracha, as a
quotation from the Behag, as a quotation
from the Behag, is then is, you have
only one way, one approach to this
Behag, one way how to understand.
Apparently if we should,
you have a Gemara Megillah?
...U'Behag kosav deheicha
deinshi levarech balaylah
heicha deinshi shochach
levarech balayla, to count
Sefiras HaOmer balaylah
yimneh lemachar belo bracha.
Vechein halacha.
Aval im shachach laylah vayom lo yimneh
od bivracha debeinan temimos veleka.
What do you say?
Aval im shachach laylah vayom lo yimneh.
He skipped it, completely, yes?
Debeinan temimos veleka.
So what is the aval,
what is the aval here?
[Answer from audience.] Tosfos says
the Behag had said two halachos.
One halacha is moneh bayom belo
bracha, and the second halacha what is?
What is?
It's not even a bracha.
Not even belo bracha.
In both cases.
Lo yimneh od b'vracha
debeinan temimos veleka.
[Inaudible].
Lo yimneh od bivracha.
So why does the Behag say
lo yimneh od belo bracha.
And Tosfos also quotes him, that shochach
balaylah moneh bayom, why belo bracha?
It is good, say a bracha.
You think that
sefirah balaylah is kosher, say a bracha.
You don't think so, so you
don't have to say anything.
What do you see from this Behag?
What do you infer from this Behag immediately?
If the, again, in my
opinion it's a taus sofer.
But anyway, Tosfos quotes the Behag.
Probably even the text in
Behag is impossible to see,
to ascertain the proper text.
It's impossible.
There are so many editions by the
Behag, and the more editions they
have the more complicated it becomes.
But however if the Tosfos'
quotation in Behag is correct,
so apparently the Behag is of the
opinion there are two
minyanim in Sefiras HaOmer.
Two minyanim.
One minyan, and with regard to one, two
kiyumim in Sefiras HaOmer, two kiyumim.
And if it's two kiyumim, is if mana
balaylah in the proper time, he
makes a bracha because he's mekayem,
he fulfills both, the mitzvas
Sefiras HaOmer at both levels.
We'll see soon what it is.
But however, if balaylah he didn't
do that, he does it bayom, he does
it bayom, his one kiyum is missing.
He still retains another kiyum.
But the other kiyum
does not require bracha.
I mean in simple words, first of
all, Sefiras HaOmer be'emes has two
parshas, has one parsha in Emor:
U'sfartem lachem mimochoras haShabbos
miyom haviachem es omer hatnufah sheva
shabbasos temimos tiheyenah... mimochoras
haShabbos hashvi'is tisperu chamishim yom.
[Inaudible] the first one...this
is number one, a mitzva.
And then in Re'eh: chag sispor
lach mehachel chermeish bakomoh.
And then is apparently is the kvius,
the kvius from Shavuos, Shavuos lanikba
depends upon the
yom hachamishim, correct?
Shavuos differs from other yomim tovim.
(Inaudible). Atzeres peamim hey, peamim vav, peamim zayin.
We because we have a stable calendar,
it's always vav, always vav.
We fix ... But bizman hareiyah, Beis
Din could designate Atzeres on any
of three days.
This is the parsha, this is
the parsha in Re'eh.
Chag Shavuos tispor lach sheva
shavuos tispor lach mehachel chermeish
bakomoh tachel lispor shiva shavuos.
Va'asisem chag shavuos lashem...
The shvuos does not depend upon the
date in the month, the monthly days, but
depends upon the 50th of Sefiras HaOmer.
Is memaila, is the sefirah
is kovea the Chag Shavuos.
The sefirah is kovea the Chag Shavuos.
...there is another kiyum from
sefiras arba'aim vetisha yomim in
order to establish the Chag Shavuos.
If it's a mitzva to establish all moadei
Hashem, vayedaber Moshe es moadei Hashem
el bnei Yisrael, it's also pertinent
to establish the yom tov of Shavuos.
The yom tov of Shavuos is
established by counting Sefiras HaOmer.
The Behag’s shitah is like that.
Let's say for instance,
shochach velo mana,
the Behag says yimneh
bayom belo bracha, correct?
The Tosfos quotes the Behag.
So they ask why belo bracha?
He doesn't have to count at all.
No.
The halacha in the kvius
for Shavuos, we don't care.
Or take the other case, the case
of shochach velo mana balaylah,
whether moneh bayom, is be'emes is
with regard to the kiyum
Sefiras HaOmer per se, it's
only made balaylah, not beyom.
But if you take Sefiras
HaOmer and you analyze it, I
mean from the viewpoint of what?
[Answer from audience.] Is Chag Shavuos, which means bayom is also good.
As far as Chag Shavuos is concerned,
there is yom and laylah, but they are not
two aristocrats...,
there is no conflict.
With regard to the mitzvas
sefirah, is laylah the halacha,
because it's like ktziras haomer,
that's what the Gemara says.
With regard to the mitzvas
sefirah, the general mitzvas
sefirah is laylah according to Behag.
Is laylah, no, is yom no
good but you need what?
Laylah.
Is memeila there is no bracha
because bracha is associated
with the mitzva ofSefiras HaOmer.
But as far, but if, but however as far as the kvius of Shavuos is concerned,
is yom also good.
Because the kvius is the same.
There's not
a single difference between yom and
laylah as far as the kvius Shavuos
is concerned.
[Question from Audience: Why can you make
a bracha the next night?] [Inaudible].
He cannot make according
to Behag. Just a moment.
Just a moment.
If the Behag is two kiyumim, he's
moneh bayom what is he missing,
he misses something bayom.
What does he miss bayom?
The kiyum from Sefiras HaOmer
al kol yachid veyachid.
This is number one.
On the other hand, he
still does another kiyum.
What is the kiyum?
From the kvius Chag Shavuos, vayedaber
Moshe es moadei Hashem el bnei Yisrael.
the kvius from Chag Shavuos.
As far as the kvius from Chag HaShavuos
is concerned, the same validity he
ascribed to the sefiras haomer balaylah,
the same importance can be ascribed
attributed to sefiras haomer bayom as
far as the kvius moadim is concerned, as
far as the Chag Shavuos ta'aseh lecha.
But the bracha, the bracha,
the tikkun habracha was on
the kiyum kol yachid veyachid, Sefiras HaOmer.
Because why is Sefiras
HaOmer no good bayom,
is because it is equated with
ktzira, and ktzira is balaylah.
It's only with regard to the
mitzvas sefiras haomer which
has nothing to do with kvius.
But the mitzvas sefiras
haomer with kvius is good
bayom and balaylah, because as far as
the dates are concerned, is the sefiras
haomer bayom, the sefiras haomer bayom
just as good and just as correct balaylah.
This is number one.
He asks the question, why if shochach the
Behag also said belo bracha,
why there belo bracha?
Mima nafshach.
If the Behag, same kashya, if the
Behag is of the opinion that you need
temimos, so he shouldn't count at all.
If the Behag is of the
opinion that temimos
is not, the requirement of temimos is,
I don't have to give up sefiras haomer
because I missed the minyan, so why?
The question what he asked is bayom
and balaylah I understand very well
that the kvius bayom takes in, ... Chag
Shavuos, is the kvius hayom is good.
But however, not the Chag Shavuos,
the kvius Chag Shavuos, but
the mitzva of sefirah per se, is no
good in sefiras haomer.
The Sefiras HaOmer of kol yachid
veyachid, is memaila, is the bracha,
the question is which aspect of
the mitzva requires a bracha.
Many mitzvos have...one
aspect...Al Biur chametz.
Al biur chametz consists of
searching the chametz, finding the
chametz and destroying the chametz.
The bracha what do you say the bracha?
[Answer from audience.] Over searching.
The question in sefirah is,
what do you say the bracha?
Over what do you say the bracha?
Over the kiyum for yachid,
mimochoras haShabbos hashvi'is tisperu chamishim yom,
chamishim yom, or you say the bracha over the kvius ... Shavuos.
Is this is in laylah and yom.
Laylah and yom says Shavuos is good bayom.
While Shavuos, the kvius Shavuos is good bayom
but there is no bracha.
Memeila is shochach velo mana
balaylah he's moneh bayom without the
bracha, because one aspect he complies
with, but he does not fulfill the second
aspect, the aspect of kvius of what?
Of shavuos.
Correct.
In temimos in shochach, the question was
raised by him, is a similar situation.
If it is in kvius, if it is in kvius, is
shochach, the halacha, if shochach
velo manah bayom, if shochach
velo mana yom min hayomim is
kovea, yes, yes, correct, correct.
The halacha is, the halacha is that once
he skipped one night, so there is no what?
There is no temimos...
I cannot go on and say hayom
asarah yomim if I skipped yesterday
hayom tisha yomim, correct?
...However, in kol
yachid veyachid it is so.
But as far as kvius Shavuos is concerned,
then I am not a kovea as a yachid, as an individual, I am a kovea as what?
As a part of the Klal Yisrael. As far as part of the Klal Yisrael, there is continuity.
There is no continuity as far as I am
concerned, but as far as the Klal Yisrael
is concerned, there is continuity.
You cannot say listen, you just say hayom asarah yomim,
how do you know that?
So ... he'll tell me,
what will he tell me?
I know that because the
tzibbur counted like that.
And I base my minyan
of the minyan hatzibbur.
This is good enough, but only to,
it's good enough with regard to what?
To kvius Shavuos.
Because kvius Shavuos does not
depend upon the yachid, the
tzibbur together is kovea Shavuos.
But as far as my duty, my chova
is concerned, my duty, namely to
count 50 days, if I missed one
I don't fulfill the mitzvah.
The fact that the tzibbur will go on with
the count, is quite helpful if it's a
problem of kvius Shavuos of the tzibbur.
But it doesn't help me at all as far
as my private mitzvah is concerned.
In a word, shochach velo mana lo
bayom velo balaylah, is the tzibbur
kovea together
with the tzibbur.
[Question from audience.] I have got,
I've got to count, but no bracha.
The bracha is again, as far
as a yachid is concerned.
In a word, the mitzvas Sefiras
HaOmer has two kiyumim.
A kiyum from just sefirah which
leads to nothing, just sefirah.
And a kiyum from kvius Shavuos.
For sheva shavuos tispor lach
mehachel chermesh bakomoh,
tachel lispor shivas shavuos.
Va'asisa chag shavuos laHashem Elokecha.
You have it also with regard in
Parshas Emor: U'sfartem lachem
mimochoras haShabbos miyom haviachem
es omer hatnufah, sheva Shabbasos
temimos tiheyenah ad mimochoras haShabbos hashvi'is tisperu...
[AUDIO CUTS OUT]
...one function is just sefirah.
The second function of
Sefiras HaOmer is keviah... And that's
the Behag who speaks the language of belo
bracha is because the
Behag's both shittos,
that bayom is pasul only balaylah
is kasher and the temimos applies
only to the chiyuv of the yachid.
As far as the kiyum hamitzvah of kevius
Shavuos which is chal on the klal
Yisrael, on beis din, is bayom
and balaylah no different.
So if I forgot to count
sefirah last night, I reminded myself
bayom, so I say right away about, I count
sefirah immediately, as far as Shavuos
is concerned, it's a good sefirah, but
he doesn't don't say a bracha because the
bracha is connected, associated with what?
With the minyan hayachid, and
this minyan hayachid is missing.
[Question from audience.] What what what?
[Question from Audience]
The Shulchan Aruch like that.
No no, you are right.
You are right, from a
viewpoint, you are right.
It's not sfek sfeika.
They all are masbir ... count
if I skip the night, but in the
daytime I caught ... the sefirah,
is then the next night I can continue.
And they say it's sfek sfeika.
You don't need sfek sfeika.
According to my pshat it
is without sfek sfeika.
If I count, he didn't count at night and
I count the daytime, is the sefirah from
kvius Yisrael, of chag Shavuos, valid.
Is the sefirah valid.
The sefirah is valid ... I
didn't count last night
I counted today.
Just a moment... What's the case?
What is the case?
The case is he forgot to make
a bracha, balaylah he didn't
count so he counts bayom.
In the next night he can
go on with a bracha...
So the Shulchan Aruch says it's
because it's a sfek sfeika.
Shema bayom is good, ... even if bayom
is, or perhaps, what's the safeik?
[Answer from audience.]
Just a moment ... Why
is there sfek sfeika?
Shema I'm able to count even if I skipped
... to count in the time ... the mitzvah.
And shema
if omitting a sefirah makes it
impossible for me to continue, perhaps
I haven't omitted a sefirah because
I counted bayom, bayom is kasher.
This is the Mechaber.
[Question from audience]
We are interested now
the way I interpreted
that I counted the day
he counts the day is a kiyum hamitzvah from kvius chag hashavuos,
and if I skipped, that's what the Behag says moneh belo bracha,
minyan is required but a minyan is valid
only vis-a-vis the kvius chag hashavuos,
but the minyan has no validity as
far as temimos or the chiyuv
hayachid is concerned.
So they say
in such a case there
should not be a bracha.
... So because, ... sfek sfeika,
it's a different story.
...if it's not sfek sfeika,
how did I interpret it?
How did I interpret?
Not with sfek sfeika, but simply:
Shochach velo mana is moneh belo
bracha, but minyan is required.
Why is minyan required?
Kvius Haregel!
Then shochach balaylah velo
mana, umana bayom.
Again, in bracha is no bracha because
there is no kiyum yachid, but there
is a minyan because the minyan has significance.
What's the significance of the minyan?
[Answer from audience.] ...Shavuos.
[Comment from audience.] ...continue.
Just a moment.
That's why the
Mechaber he utilizes sfek sfeika
in order to make it possible
for him to say a bracha.
The Mechaber says sfeika, the
Mechaber says sfek sfeika.
So the question is,
what does the sfek sfeika give us?
[Answer from audience.] The inclusion
of the bracha in the next sefirah.
Because if not for sfek sfeika,
I would say alright I can continue
count, without a bracha until Shavuos, and
Shavuos will be established with the count
without a bracha, even though he skipped.
This ... what you meant.
[Question from audience.]
Please Please.
Yeah yeah, go ahead.
[Question from Audience.]
..According to
the Behag... shochach velo mana
balaylah moneh bayom belo bracha.
Why?
Because the kvias tzibbur
is present here.
But what does he need?
But there is no bracha because the
bracha is connected with the yachid.
So how does a
yachid regain the privilege of
the bracha?
[Comments from audience.]
The way I interpreted, that according
to the Behag, the Behag said it
eino yotzei yedei chovaso, or
with regard to the chovas Sefiras
HaOmer shel kol yachid veyachid.
As far as the tzibbur is
concerned, the Behag never said it.
Is mimeilah, whatever the Behag
said that invalidates this
sefirah, it invalidates only with
regard to kiyum alef, to the aspect of
the kiyum from sefiras hayachid.
The kiyum from sefiras hatzibbur,
the Behag did not say that the
sefirah ...the sefirah is important
because it will be ... kvias hatzibur.
[Comment from Audience]
...tzibbur but no bracha.
But not bracha.
The Shulchan Aruch says no, he makes
a bracha, the Mechaber says if
you have the combination of two,
sefirah from kol yachid veyachid and
the kvias hatzibbur, there is a bracha.
That's what the Mechaber says, and this
is based upon the sfek sfeika.
So, this is sfek sfeika, nu.
So what is the kashya?
The Mechaber says it's a sfek sfeika.
In Behag it's impossible to
formulate, to see I mean ... the Behag
didn't say sfek sfeika, the
Behag didn't say anything.
...Shavuos is nikbah, the kiyum from
yachid is poka, because he missed.
And then what do you do
the rest of the sefirah?
I do the rest of the
sefirah...I make no bracha.
This is the Mechaber,
because of sfek sfeika.
[Comments from audience.]
The Behag says ... shochach velo mana
is balaylah habo, ...moneh belo bracha.
Why is belo bracha?
[Comments from audience.] What
sfek sfeika, I explained it,
not sfek sfeika, I explained
the halacha that there is a kiyum,
it's not just a waste of time.
[Comments from audience.]
No.
Without sfek sfeika I mean he wouldn't be
able... [Comments from audience.]
The Behag says that he continues
to count, without a bracha.
We asked why without a bracha.
[Comments from audience.]
For instance, at night he forgot,
he counts the fourteenth during
the daytime with no bracha.
[Comments from audience.] All the
following nights he counts with a bracha.
You have the text?
The Tosfos that Tosfos
quotes the Behag?
[Audience member reads the Behag.]
If shochach laylah...bayom,
without a bracha.
Aval im shochach laylah
veyom lo yimneh od bevracha.
Why is laylah veyom different?
Laylah veyom, aval Im shochach
laylah veyom lo yimneh od bevracha.
So he goes on without a bracha.
[Comments from audience.] If siper
bayom... [Comments from audience.]
But the continuity...
Alright, let's forget the Rashi.
But the Behag, Behag is like that.
If he forgot balaylah,
moneh bayom belo bracha.
This is shitas Behag, because with
regard to kiyum hayachid, is yom
no good, is only laylah the zman sefirah.
However,
the next night, he's moneh bebracha.
Why is moneh bebracha?
Because yes, the
next night when he's moneh,
when he counts, he counts
bevracha, for a simple reason.
Because, the mitzvas hayachid, in
the mitzvas hayachid, is laylah vayom
play no role in mitzvas hayachid.
On the contrary, in mitzvas hayachid
is laylah vayom, in kvius from
Beis Din from klal Yisrael is yom
and layalah makes no difference,
yom valayalah makes no difference.
But the bracha, there is no bracha
because in yachid it is kasher
only balaylah not bayom, not bayom.
But when ... the next
sefirah is already a sefirah
balaylah, it's a sefirah
balaylah, there is a bracha.
[Comment from the audience.]
I didn't say each night
is a separate mitzvah.
I didn't say each night.
All I said, if the, please.
All I said is if, I asked what does
...yispor belo bebracha what sense does
it make as far as the Behag is concerned.
If laylah is good and yom
is no good, lo yispor klal.
Is yom is good, so yispor bebracha.
So we answered, that in the kiyum
from yachid is only balaylah, but
there is another kiyum in Sefiras
HaOmer which is good bayom as well,
because it's the same kevius...
Is mimeilah, shochach velo manah balaylah
is moneh bayom belo bracha, there is no
bracha because the bracha is exclusively
connected with yachid, there is only
the kiyum from shiva
shavuos tispor lach, ...
from kvius from shvuos, and kvius from shvuos is yom kasher.
But there is no bracha.
Why is there no bracha?
Because now it is night, now it is night and the bracha is taluy in yachid.
Now it is day I mean.
...the zeman mitzvah is balaylah, is
mimeilah he's moneh belo bracha because
there is no kiyum hayachid.The kiyum
hayachid is, is sefirah is balaila.
...kezayis matzah is balaylah,
the sefira is balaylah.
But however in kvius hatzibbur,
there is no zman laylah veyom.
The zman is, this depends whether
it is the same count or it's
a different count, and laylah
veyom don't differ in the count.
Mimeilah is laylah vayom don't differ
in the count, ... the chovas kevius
shvuos I fulfilled, what is missing is
... chelek hayachid ... there is no bracha.
Why no bracha?
Because now when I am counting bayom,
I don't yotzei the mitzvah from
Sefiras HaOmer, totally, total Sefiras
HaOmer, is both kiyumim, that's why
there is no bracha.
But this is only to one day
because now it is yom.
But the next, tomorrow, a bracha balaylah.
I did not lose it because yesterday's
sefirah was also a good sefirah,
with regard to kvius Chag HaShavuos.
And since yesterday's sefirah is a good
sefirah, ... Chag HaShavuos, is that
temimos is eliminated,
...temimos ... maintained, maintained.
mimeilah ...now I cannot say a bracha,
because there's no mitzvas yachid.
Why is no mitzvas yachid?
Because it's daytime.
It's only balaylah.
But next night is a
mitzvas yachid as well.
Both kiyumim.
And the fact that I
counted at the daytime,
it means I saved the continuity,
continuous, ...mimeilah is a bracha.
What is here?
... veod nireh deafilu leman demachshir
ktziras homer bayom dieved modeh hu
legabei sefirah de'ein levarech bayom
mishum deshana alav hakasuv leakev,
dichsiv temimos, ve'i atah motzeh
temimos elah kesheatah moneh balaylah.
U'Behag kosav deheichah deinshi levarech
balaylah, yimneh lemachar bayom belo
bracha, vechein halacha, aval im shachach
laylah vayom lo yimneh od bivracha.
Why?
Debeinan temimos.
If shochach laylah vayom, there is
no temimos there is no continuity.
But if zachar bayom, there is continuity.
Why is there continuity?
Because there is another
kiyum which he maintained.
Namely, the kiyum from
kvius Chag HaShavuos.
Is mimeilah, why doesn't he
make a bracha on the daytime?
Because the yachid is, a sefirah
beyachid requires laylah,like a
kezayis matzah requires laylah.
But this is not a zman
from kvius beis din.
Kvius beis din balaylah
is a tartei desasrei.
Kvius beis din is not layom
valaylah, but what's kevius beis din?
Whether it is the same
minyan as laylah or not,
and since hayom holech achar halaylah,
is kevius beis din the same minyan, bayom
... kvius beis din ... the same minyan as if
I had counted last night.
Is mimeilah is no bracha.
But no bracha only on the day, I count,
I do count bayom.
But lemachar is ... a mayseh
sefirah balaylah, kemitzvasah.
When the continuity was saved by what?
By the sefirah from kvius Chag HaShavuos.
Is mimeilah he is mivarech
bebracha, that's how Tosfos...next night.
Now, now there is only one question.
I don't understand why the people,
why you didn't ask me... This question
is, if there is now one question which
is very important than anything else.
Is Chag HaShavuos, is it
actually, Chag HaShavuos
is nikba through sefirah?
The same manner as the yovel
is nikba through sefirah.
The Beis Din Hagadol used to count every
year, Rosh Hashana, Yom Kippur, we don't
know exactly, count ... say, hashana hi
shnas hashviis lishmita rishonah l'yovel.
The Beis Din Hagadol used to do.
The Rayvad, the Rambam,
the Ramban, all have that.
[...Comment from audience.]
Correct, correct, correct.
Is mimeilah, if there is
no sefirah, is no Shavuos.
Because Shavuos is not talui in
a date, it is a date, but the
mikadesh, ... shvuos, is a maaseh sefirah.
The gemara in Rosh Hashana says, amrah
Torah maneh shanim, vekadesh yovel.
Amrah Torah maneh yomim vekadesh Atzeres.
A gemara in Rosh Hashana.
It is the same, the same kvius, which
yovel gets from the minyan hashemittos,
so Shavuos gets from the minyan hayomim.
The gemara.
This is the gemara.
So the question is, the question is, and
if there is no sefirah, no minyan for
yemei hasefirah,
you'd have no Shavuos.
Is it possible to say?
I would say the following, as far
as the Knesses Yisrael is concerned,
they'll always, we believe that
Yisrael will always perform or
fulfill the mitzvas sefirah.
So there is no,
no menace threatening, I
mean, the survival of Shavuos.
But what do you do, most rishonim
are of the opinion, hasefirah
bizman hazeh is derabbanan.
Which means mideoraysa
there is no sefirah.
How can there
be a Chag HaShavuos mideoraysa,
and sefirah miderabbanan?
If, of course, if we say that
the maaseh hasefirah, then I say
hayom ... yom echad baomer, so I
say and Shavuos is 49 days off.
When I say shnei yomim baomer,
implicitly there is a kevius
for Shavuos ... sefirah,
which is effective
as far as Shavuos is
concerned... there's no sefirah.
Ameimar manah yomei
velo manah shvuei,
amar zecher lemikdash.
It's actually when you
take a look in the Medrash Shochar Tov
of Devarim, the Medrash Shochar Tov says
Chag Shavuos ta'aseh lach, so the Medrash
Shochar Tov says afilu bizman hazeh.
Afilu bizman hazeh.
Why didn't the Medrash Shochar
Tov say that about Pesach
and Sukkos, Rosh HaShannah?
...Atzeres?
Because there is no sefirah.
I believe that there is
something which
we forgot to take into consideration.
... in general kvius moadim.
... in general kvius moadim bizman hazeh.
How is it?
... kvius moadim determined upon reiyah.
Edus came and said ... Beis Din
is kovea the chodesh, and the
chodesh is the reiyah is nikvah in
accordance with kevius beis din.
But bizman hazeh there is no
reiyah, how is there kvius moadim?
So the Rambam has
this question, in perek hei
hilchos kiddush hachodesh, and
he gives a very simple answer.
There is a halacha leMoshe
miSinai ... moadim are
nikbah through two methods.
One method what?
One method is reiyah, this is bizman
haMikdash, uvizman Beis Din Hagadol,
be... halishkah lishkas hagazis.
And another halacha leMoshe miSinai is
that cheshbon, the moadim
are nikbah through chesbon.
By whom are they nikbah?
By the Klal Yisrael ...cheshbon?
The chesbon ... the chesbon
...You know be'emes we have the same
question we have vis-a-vis Shavuos,
so the same question actually
applies to moadim in general.
How are moadim bizman
hazeh possible?
Since eileh moadei Hashem
asher tikreu osum mikraei
kodesh, I mean, does not apply to us,
because we require kvius beis din, and
bizman hazeh we don't
have kvius beis din.
Nevermind Shavuos, now I'm asking
about ... Bizman Hazeh there is
no kevius [inaudible].
What is the answer according to the Rambam? What is the answer?
Cheshbon.
When there is no kvius beis
din, there is kviah by itself,
kviah by itself, through what?
Through cheshbon.
This is Shavuos the same halacha.
Be'emes is Shavuos requires kevius
not beis din, kevias kol yisrael.
By what halacha?
By the halachos of sefirah,
by the mitzvah of sefirah.
The sha'ar moadim, bizman
habayis ... what is the kovea?
Reiyah.
Reiyah is sefirah, but different.
... But there was a body, beis din as a
separate entity used to be kovea what?
Use to be kovea all moadim on
the basis of reiyah, and kovea
Shavuos on the basis of what?
Of Sefiras HaOmer.
Chorav Beis HaMikdash is batel sefirah.
Chorav Beis HaMikdash is batel reiyah.
Is batel reiyah is batel, so there is no
Beis Din Hagadol there is no one to, on
the Har HaBayis now of Beis Din HaGadol.
So always we are not left without
moadim, but a mekadesh changes.
Instead of reiyah, what is
a mekadesh bizman hazeh?
Kevia al yedei cheshbon.
Instead of sefirah,
there is another kovea.
The kovea from Sefirah is
a kovea al yedei ma'aseh
beis din, Klal Yisrael.
There is another kovea,
what is the other kovea?
In Chesbon, is sefirah, the maaseh
sefirah whether it's mideoraysa or
miderabanan lo maaleh velo morid.
The chesbon which is kovea Pesach ... by
the kevius of Pesach, because sefirah
is dependent upon, the moed for Shavuos
... Shavuos doesn't have a separate zman.
Shavuos does not have a separate zeman.
It has a kevius from Pesach, what
is kovea pesach is kovea Shavuos.
Is bazman hazeh, sefirah
mideoraysa is not sefirah the kovea
but the Klal Yisrael through cheshbon.
But bizman habayis, ... reiyah was
number one, but there is sefirah.
The only question is, since bizman
hazeh there is no sefirah, sefirah not
the kovea, what's the kovea?
The cheshbon.
So why should I be mekayem
a mitzvah if I should count
sefirah, fulfill a double mitzvah.
Bizman hazeh...what is kovea?
The cheshbon.
What is the cheshbon?
From Pesach is kovea.
Chamishim yom.
What I'm interested is to say is that
there is a maaseh kevius on Shavuos.
Shavuos is not like Pesach,
Pesach has no maaseh kevius.
Shavuos is, if you have to say,
...mimachoras hashabbat until Shavuos,
hayom hayom hayom hayom, and this
maaseh kevius, which hundreds of Jews
or thousands of Jews say is kovea.
The question is, what is bizman hazeh?
If sefirah is miderabanan?
What did we answer?
There is Shavuos ... chesbon from
Pesach, is sefirah is not a factor
bizman hazeh, the factor bizman hazeh
is not sefirah, but what is the factor?
[Inaudible] [Answer from audience.]
The chesbon ...the cheshbon of Pesach.
Is mimeilah, the sefirah [inaudible]
is only one aspect, is not a mikadesh
bizman hazeh ... one kiyum in sefirah,
namely the chovas hayachid and not
a mitzvah from kevius beis din.
This is the only difficulty I
encountered with [inaudible].
[Question from audience]
You may say that miderabanan
is sefirah also a kovea, but
mideoraysa you don't need it.
Mideoraysa you have the
kevius from chesbon.
Umiderabanan...yeah
Now that Sefirah is a kovea, that sefirah
is a kovea, bizman habayis definitely, but
perhaps bizman hazeh too,
is the chachmei
hakabbalah accepted it.
Because the chachmei hakabbalah
had a different interpretation
of the minhag yisrael which
considered sefirah a zman aveilus.
Of course, I mean, we take for granted
that sefirah is a zman aveilus,
because of talmidei Rabbi Akiva.
...Rabbi Akiva's talmidim died, so
many thousands of them died, ...Pesach
LeAtzeres ... batlah Torah miYisrael.
This is our interpretation.
And within, within the frame of
reference of this interpretation
that the aveilus of yemei hasefirah
is due to the incident,
the Talmidei Rabbi Akiva,
in conjunction with
this interpretation, we consider the
aveilus from Sefirah as limited, it
means before, lamed gimmel baomer.
The balance between Lag BaOmer and
Shavuos, [inaudible] no aveilus.
But the Gemara in Yevamos says, shekulam
meisu b'fros atzeres, which means 14 days
before Atzeres, it's around Lag BaOmer.
The 14 days ...shekulam meisu, and that's
why the Mechaber says that lamed gimmel
baomer is still included in aveilus.
But Lamed Daled baboker, miktzas hayom kekulo, is the aveilus terminated.
Terminated and forgotten.
The Rama, the Rama says that
our minhag is not like this.
Our minhag is that
Lag BaOmer itself, that after Lag
BaOmer, we still continue to
observe yemei aveilus of sefirah.
But Lag BaOmer itself for some
unknown reason, Lag BaOmer
itself is a Yom Tov though.
What is the Yom Tov for?
But anyway, this is the shita of the Rama.
This is shitas HaRama, and shittas
HaBeis Yosef is the source of aveilus
during days of Sefirah is some historical
event which took place 1800, 1900 years ago.
The aveilus was imposed
later bizman Rabbi Akiva.
The Mekubalim have a different viewpoint.
They say that Sefirah itself
contains the experience of aveilus.
Where there is vesafrah, sefirah,
the act of of counting, of counting tumas
hameis, zav and zava, metzora, to count,
we just read the parshiyos.
...u'safrah lah shivas
yomim letahorosah.
V'safra lah, is during the shivas yomim, which there is nihug aveilus.
In metzora we find, in
Chumash,... a metzora is a naval.
We have ibayos in the Gemara in Moed
Katan, which issurei aveilus are
are applicable to kohein gadol or not.
But it's a davar pashut that there
is an element of aveilus
in metzora, mideoraysa aveilus.
Al safam yaateh, many of the practices of aveilus which we Rachmana litzlan observe
is due to the fact that we
consider the observance of tzora'as as
an aveilus, as an aveilus experience.
Wherever there is vesafrah lah, vesafar lo, shivas yomim
tisper lo, is there is aveilus.
Umimeilah, hence, the minhagim which
are asur, their issur is applicable
to the pre-Lag BaOmer period and
to the post-Lag BaOmer period.
It is the same Sefirah, you
cannot say that the Sefirah
is terminated by Lag BaOmer.
The Sefirah is during the
entire period of Sefiras HaOmer.
Vesofrah, vesofrah,
means when a man suffers.
[Comment from audience.] Just a moment.
Just a moment.The Halacha from Sefirah.
Why is it so?
Why is Sefirah a symbol of ... and
the Sefirah, because each Sefirah,
be'emes we have Sefirah only with regard
to a naval,
to I mean, with regard to tumah.
Where do you have Sefirah in the Torah?
Tumah, in tumah.
Shivas yomim, zav v'zava, tumas
meis, tumas meis, what else?
Niddah?
Ah?
[Anser from audience] What?
Metzora...When one has to emerge
from the depths of tumah into a
world of taharah, is this process of
emerging, this is a process of teshuva,
basically it is the process of teshuva.
This process of emerging from a
dark, contaminated, defiled world
into a world, shekulo tov, this
process itself is one of suffering.
Baalei teshuva, I mean, enjoy still later.
But a baal teshuva I mean, when he
goes through the period of hakaras
hachet and vidui, vidui devarim, and
when he has to surrender completely,
surrender completely, and when he has
to accuse himself, to indict himself,
I mean, of the aveiros he committed.
All this is suffering.
And it is self... and the whole
hakaras hachet is self-torture.
Is mimeilah ... that if the Jews in
Mitzrayim were in the mem-tes shaarei
tumah, and they had to emerge into a
world of Sinai, of Kabbalas HaTorah
and gilui Shechinah, this emergence,
because of the contrast,
because the contrast is so, is so
amazingly different, frightening, just
seven weeks before, they were at the
bottom of shaarei tumah, of complete
degradation and complete corruption,
and on Shavuos they already stood at the
foot ... of the mountain, and they shouted
naaseh v'nishma, they were at the apex.
But this slow, slow climbing,
climbing from the bottom of the
mountain, the tachtis hahar, to the
top of the of the mountain, this
climbing is very difficult, replete
with suffering.
And this is Sefiras HaOmer.
And that's why there is aveilus.
Why there is aveilus.
...this is according to Mekubalim.
And the Mekubalim the minhag
by many many is not to observe
aveilus ... on lamed gimmel baomer.
Because according to that interpretation,
is lamed gimmel baomer not much
different from the previous, from
the days, from pre-Lag BaOmer days.
[Question from the
audience] What do you say?
[Question from the audience] [Inaudible]
and since I didn't answer him, I
don't have to answer you either.
It's a different kind of Sefirah.
A different kind of Sefirah.
[Comment from the audience]
I don't need a terutz, [inaudible].
If you read the parsha,
please, if you read the parsha
from Sefiras HaOmer, please.
If you read the parsha of Sefiras
HaOmer the way it appears in Emor,
in the kriah of the Shabbos which
will come, we encounter difficulties
in understanding the parsha.
The parsha says as
follows, it's very strange:
...Here it is.
The Torah speaks about Pesach: chamishah
asar yom lachodesh hazeh chag
hamatzos lashem, shivas yomim matzos
tocheilu, bayom harishon mikra
kodesh, vehikravtem isheh ladoshem
shivas yomim, bayom harishon mikra
kodesh, kol meleches avodah lo sa'asu.
...Good, fine.
Then suddenly, vayidaber
Adoshem el Moshe leimor.
What does it mean?
Daber el Bnei Yisrael veamarta
aleihem ki savo'u el ha'aretz asher
Ani nosein lachem, Whenever your
come, you'll cross into the land of
Eretz Yisrael, uktzartem es ktzirah.
You will harvest the land.
Vahaveisem es omer reishis ktzirchem el hakohen.
Veheinif hakohein...yenifenu
Hakohein. Va'asisem beyom hanifchem
es haomer, keves tomim...velechem
vekoli vecharmel...Usfartem
lachem mimochoras haShabbos
miyom haviachem es omer hatnufah,
sheva Shabbasos temimos tiheyena.
Ad mimochoras haShabbos hashvi'is
tisperu chamishim yom vehikravtem mincha
chadasha laHashem and so on, and so on.
Basically, is
the Torah speaks before about Yom
Hashvi'i, bayom hashvi'i mikra
kodesh kol meleches avodah lo sa'asu.
And then the Torah after Yom Hashvi'i
begins to speak immediately about what?
About Sefiras HaOmer and
Chodosh... It should
have been differently.
Should have been, Eileh
moadei Hashem mikraei kodesh asher
tikreu osam bemoadam, vehikravtem isheh
laHashem shivas yomim bayom hashvi'i
mikrah kodesh, kol meleches avodah lo
sa'asu, before daber el Bnei Yisrael
v'amarta aleihem ki savo'u el ha'aretz
u'ketzartem es ktzirah, because this is on
the second day, and
this is the seventh day.
In general is, why is it necessary to say
... chi savo'u el ha'aretz asher Ani nosein
lachem u'ktzartem es ktzirah v'haveisem
es omer reishis ketzirchem el hakohen.
Why is it all that
necessary to say?
The Torah should have said, I mean,
...chodosh and vekoli vecharmel
lo sochlu ad etzem hayom hazeh.
The impression when
we study the parsha, what we get as
if the Torah is deviating from the
theme and picks up a different theme
which is important.
Basically, the
Sefiras HaOmer, if you
remember, [inaudible].
Sefiras HaOmer represents something
which was frightening to the people,
to the Jews who came out of Mitzrayim,
who were in Mitzrayim, something which
apparently they couldn't understand
well what it is, and they were afraid.
What was the problem?
The problem was a simple one.
We have in the safrus hadrush, drush
and machshava, we have it in Mekubalim,
in the ... HaMekubalim, Kabbalah, that
with Yetzi'as Mitzrayim, a certain
definitive rift took place, Yetzi'as
Mitzrayim, Yetzi'as Mitzrayim, excuse me.
The Jews expected,
excuse me...As long as the people
were in Mitzrayim, they were under
hashgacha, hashgacha al-tivis,
a supranatural dimension.
The event, the event which happened
in Mitzrayim, when I say events
happened in Mitzrayim, I mean both,
before Moshe arrived with the message
of geulah, and after it arrived,
the message of geulah, ushered in
an era, an era in Jewish history.
This era, I mean, if you'll just
count Moshe's arrival, about 40 years.
If this era started already, began,
it was ushered in prior to Moshe,
so it was a hundred years old.
Namely that the Jews were placed
under the perspective and under
hashgacha pratis, al-nissis
I mean, supernatural hashgacha.
Because if
HaKadosh Baruch Hu had not employed
this method, so one of the methods
of hashgacha which HaKadosh Baruch
Hu employs from time to time, the
method of hashgacha, al-nissis.
Ayin Lamed Nun Samech Yud
Suf, means, supernatural.
The categories which are reflected
by such a hashgacha are not the categories
of causality, of natural causality which
prevail in the physical as well as
in the historical world.
It's categories we don't understand.
Which simply defy causality, naturalness,
and unity of the cosmic process.
Those hashgacha, this hashgacha pratis,
this hashgacha not pratis, lemaalah
min hateva, al-tiv'is, this hashgacha
pratis was launched, I
mean, sponsored by
HaKadosh Baruch Hu with his
appointment appointing Moshe,
when he spoke to him,
es ha'osos vehamofsim.
Moshe's task was ... he should
be the representative and the
leader of a community or of a
society which will be guided from
the first day Moshe came to
Mitzrayim until, until what time?
Until what time?
Until the entry into Eretz Yisrael,
will be placed completely in the
dimensions of hashgacha tiv'is,
of hashgacha, nissis, al-tiv'is,
hashgacha lemaalah min hateva.
Different I mean.
...the question..., which for 40
years people were nourished, I mean,
in a manner which we cannot imagine,
cannot understand now how it was.
...question of Krias Yam Suf, zeh
Keili veanveihu, as Chazal say
that each infant or each child, I mean,
pointed out with his little finger,
there is God... kind of gilui Shechinah.
But not every dor, not
every dor, no dor has
achieved such distinction.
And no dor, and no dor, no generation,
no generation was placed completely,
completely under the cloth of al-nissi.
Supernatural.
The cosmic order did not function
as far as the Jews in Mitzrayim
and the midbar are concerned.
Basically is, we hope that this order will
be renewed and will be reestablished at
the time of the final geulah,
redemption.
Kimei tzeischa me'eretz mitzrayim arenu niflaos.
But Mitzrayim, Yetzi'as Mitzrayim
represents what kind of hashgacha?
Osos umofsim. Lemaalah min hateva.
An hashgacha
that you can put over to this
table and scratch it and it should
be, and there should be, the
table should start hemorrhaging.
Lechem min hashamayim.
The Torah min hashamayim.
The onesh, onshin, the
penalties are swift in coming.
Are swift, are swift in coming.
As a matter of fact, people ask, why is
it, why when the Bnei Aharon, the kashya
is be'emes Chazal raised the kashya.
The Bnei Aharon, what did they do?
Not a vulgar aveirah.
Moshe Rabbeinu said about
Bnei Aharon that.
Bekrovai ekodesh.
And I thought that bekrovai
ekodesh refers to us.
But now I find out, I found out that
the Bnei Aharon were superior to us.
Why is it
so that the punishment
was so swift in coming?
Quickly, swift in coming.
And we ask,
in history, even if HaKadosh
Baruch Hu punishes somebody
for chet, he's not so swift.
Notzer chesed la'alafim,
rav chesed veemes.
Ve'ad yom moso techakeh lo.
The attribute of HaKadosh
Baruch Hu is rav chesed ve'emes.
The Chazal say, ... vayimaher
Moshe vayikod artzcha vayishtachu.
... Chazal vayishtachu.
What did he hear when
he prostrated himself?
So one says emes.
And we say, ...one man deamar
says chessed.
Because the whole emes, the
methods of teshuva would have been
completely irrelevant if HaKadosh
Baruch Hu had exercised middas
haemes and not middas hachesed.
HaKadosh Baruch Hu's patience
and perseverance and his
graciousness as a baal
hachesed makes teshuva workable,
makes teshuva possible.
If Hakadosh Baruch Hu had dealt with
chotim in the same manner as he dealt with
Nadav veAvihu, so the whole promise of
teshuva would have been completely wasted,
would have been completely wasted.
What's the use of HaKadosh
Baruch Hu as a mikabel biteshuva?
It takes the sinner,
it takes the sinner a couple
of years before he gets
used to the idea of teshuva.
But the trouble is if the same method
which HaKadosh Baruch Hu applied to
Nadav veAvihu would be applied to
any choteh, so then the whole
Yom Kippur has absolutely
no significance.
And that's what Chazal say,
vayimaher Moshe vayishtachu.
Ma ra'ah?
What did he hear?
He heard something
which quieted his heart.
And he was not, which actually gave
him a, making him understand that
the message of
teshuva is valid and will be carried
out, implemented, because HaKadosh
Baruch Hu will not push the choteh.
He will stand only at the door and
will wait for the choteh to come.
If this is the case, and now in rav
chesed v'emes, one of the 13 attributes,
when you...ochez biyad midas mishpat, we
announce quite solemnly ve'ad yom moso
techakeh lo, im yashuv miyad tekablo.
HaKadosh Baruch Hu has patience kaveyachol
to wait for a choteh
to do teshuva,
the whole lifespan of 70 or 80 years.
So why wasn't this chesed
bestowed upon Nadav vaAvihu?
And in general, I think in
Tanach, not only Nadav vaAvihu.
For instance ... we read it in Shemini.
Dovid, Dovid made a mistake.
The aron habris was not carried
on the shoulders of the
kohanim and halvi'im, but ba'agalah,
in a wagon, in a carriage.
...avodas hakodesh aleihem bakosef yisau.
Is right away, ...they still
were marching to the place of
the aron, where the aron had
to be enshrined.
Then suddenly vayach Adoshem makah
aza, and Uza, the whole manager of
this affair, Uza, whom Dovid entrusted,
whom Dovid entrusted with actually
executing the transfer of the aron
into Nov VeGivon, into the Beis
Hamikdash, this Uza died immediately.
After all, it's not an issur
kares, ki avodas hakodesh
aleihem bakosef yisau,
Why so suddenly?
Why did his death actually, I mean,
take place on the same day, and
and the whole simcha was completely eliminated and so forth?
What is the answer?
The answer is, those people lived not under hashgacha tivis
but under hashgacha al-tivis,
lema'ala min hateva.
And if the adono shel olam
is good enough to change cosmic
order in order to save or to
protect a certain community or a
yachid, this particular community
or this particular yachid
must not make any mistake.
If Hakadosh Baruch Hu breaks the
cosmic order in order to facilitate
and to make it simpler for the yachid
to achieve what he wants, the way
Hakadosh Baruch Hu broke all the
precedents with regard to Dovid.
Who was Dovid?
Dovid was a shepherd boy.
And apparently, according to
Chazal, whether shepherd boy we
say it in yiddish [yiddish phrase].
The family didn't think
much of Dovid as a leader.
You see even Shmuel, could not
believe that this is the leader of
a Melech Yisrael, who will be the
ancestor of the Melech Hamoshiach.
[Inaudible] When Avishai opens his
mouth ... Dovid, You see that
he had more
regard for them.
And the Medrash tells us Baruch haba
beshem Adoshem,
keil hashem vayoer lanu isru chag
ba'avosim ad karnos hamizbeach.
Who said it?
Avishai said it.
Because Avishai considered
Dovid as a retarded [inaudible].
And suddenly the navi came
and anoints Dovid with
the shemen hamishcha and
said that he's the Melech Yisrael.
Keil Adoshem vayor lanu.
Suddenly, suddenly Dovid, and the
hashgacha, the hashgacha nisis was spread
like a cloth which is spread to protect
somebody from moisture and ... cold.
It was spread over
Dovid's head all his life.
And that's why ...Dovid should
have been doubly sure about the
legitimate, about the halacha with
regard to the transfer of an aron.
And even if the mistake is a
small one, a very mild mistake,
he shouldn't have made a mistake.
When a Jew bizman hazeh makes a
mistake, is the Jew bizman hazeh
is not tachas hashgacha nisis,
he is tachas hashgachas hateva.
The natural, under the
natural cosmic order.
Nothing in the cosmos changes for us.
No nissim geluim ...what
we call no nissim geluim.
Then is the cosmic order according
to Chazal came to an end with
Esther Hamalka.
Already Esther Hamalka worked not with
miracles, she worked a lot with wisdom
and seichel and tact and understanding.
She [inaudible].
And this is why, why it was
[inaudible] very simple.
Achashverosh signed the order.
His hand suddenly was paralyzed,
or Achashverosh, he could have
died the same night he signed the order.
Because the nes Purim is a nes lemata
min hanes, lemata bederech hateva.
It was bederech hateva.
It was a different, a
different order given.
The cosmic orderliness
and the causal nexus which
causality is responsible for, was
not noticeable, I say noticeable in
the incident with Esther and Achashverosh.
And Hakadosh Baruch Hu let Esther
do, use her own wisdom, her own
intelligence and planning, But he
did not place Esther and the Knesses
Yisrael at that time under hashgacha
al-tivis, or lema'ala min hateva.
Esther was the last book of the kisvei
hakodesh, in all other books of kisvei
hakodesh, is the events described, events
from Dovid and Shlomo Rechavam, the events
described is lema'ala miderech hateva.
If it's lema'ala miderech
hateva, the reward comes swiftly,
but the punishment comes as
quickly as the reward.
And that's why when we read
the Chumash about makas
bechoros, we don't understand
what it's all about.
Hakadosh Baruch Hu said that we
should bring a Paschal lamb, and
offer the Paschal lamb as a what?
As a protection against the malach
hamashchis who is supposed to
touch not only the Mitzrim but to
punish the, not only to punish the
Mitzrim ... but to protect the Yisrael?
No.
The malach apparently could have punished
the Yisrael and the Mitzrim as well.
And apparently there was not much,
there wasn't much reason to
simply, I mean, to defend Yisrael
because if later in Krias Yam Suf,
this was Uza's taynah.
halalu halalu halalu
halalu halalu [inaudible].
So the reason that the Yisrael
won the trial,
according to Chazal.
Yisrael and Mitzrayim.
Both were not good.
But apparently the reason
for the Bnei Yisrael,
the reason for the fact that the Bnei
Yisrael have won the trial, and the
Mitzrim have lost the trial, is not to be
searched for in the dimension of hashgacha
tivis, but of hashgacha al tivis.
This itself is the greatest of all nissim.
And in order that the
Yisrael should deserve to be saved and
survive this
catastrophe from Krias
Yam Suf, they needed a special korban.
And this is the korban from Pesach.
Al shem shepasach Hakadosh Baruch
Hu al batei avoseinu beMitzrayim.
...benagpo es mitzrayim
ve'es bateinu hitzil.
...What's all bateinu, what is bateinu?
We are the slaves, we ...suffer.
So of course we should
have been saved.
Not the Mitzrim.
The answer is that apparently we
were guilty as well as the Mitzrim.
But at least it was quite close
to the guilt of the Mitzrim.
There was guilt on the part of
Yisrael and guilt on the Mitzrim.
There is a ish Mitzri makeh
ish Ivri and so forth.
ish Mitzri makeh ish Ivri, shnei ivrim
nitzim and so forth, there are many many.
The , [inaudible] meraglim.
Apparently there was no reason rationally,
rationally, the ratio, which is
the representative of the
reason, the representative of the
hashgacha tivis, logically the
Bnei Yisrael should have lost.
For a simple reason, because the
Mitzrim had nobody to teach them.
The Bnei Yisrael who were Bnei
Avraham Yitzchak veYaakov.
So their responsibility
was by far above that,
a different one.
And this itself, that they haven't
inherited anything from Avraham,
Yitzchak veYaakov, this itself
was responsible for the possibility,
it's a strange possibility, that the
Bnei Yisrael will be found guilty,
Rachmana litzlan, and the Mitzrim,
the Mitzrim will be set free.
That's why you needed a special
korban, this is the korban haPesach.
To protect the Bnei Yisrael from what?
From the Hamalach Hamashchis because
there was a confrontation,
as Chazal tell us, between Malach
Michael and Uzza, who is guilty
and who is, who should be set free.
Only the korban made it possible.
For the hashgacha, for the hashgacha
al tivis, for the hashgacha
lema'ala min hateva, that those
nissim were carried out if
we have not deserved this.
[Inaudible] Because if it is
lema'ala min hateva, so the one who
is protected by hashgacha lema'ala
min hateva should be perfect.
Should be clean and perfect.
A little stain can change the
whole historical, the course of
historical events... The ... korban
pesach [inaudible] this
is the korban which saves.
This is the Rabban Gamliel said
shlosha dvarim ...bapesach. We
don't know what is Pesach.
Matzah we understand.
It's geulah, sudden
geulah, but what is Pesach?
Pesach is because there was logically,
reasonably, the Jews could have
lost the trial, and the Mitzrim
could have won the trial.
And this is what korban
Pesach is [inaudible].
This exactly Yetzias Mitzrayim.
But such a situation cannot continue
forever, such a situation, that a people
should exist only by being protected by
Hakadosh Baruch Hu under his private care,
under his care and love to
such an extent that the laws of
nature, the laws of history should
be considered completely completely
invalid and completely superfluous.
This cannot be forever.
It can last for a hundred years.
It can last for ten years, for
a year during Moshe's reign.
So it lasted for how long?
For a year in Mitzrayim, when Moshe
came about and forty years in midbar.
...the midbar,
the whole existence, the whole existence
in the midbar is lema'ala min hateva.
But the very moment they crossed
the Jordan river, and there was no
amud haanan anymore, and no be'erah
shel Miriam, no amud haanan, and
no man from heaven, is the ... is
to exist like any other nation, but differently.
To exist tachas derech hateva.
So these people are accustomed to live
in an order which actually ignores the
cosmic categories in history, the
cosmic laws in history, it's a very
difficult, difficult suggestion.
The Bnei Yisrael
who left Mitzrayim and went into the
midbar, they did not think that at
any time in history the hashgacha
pratis will be removed from them.
And they'll always be under the
hashgacha, under the order of lema'ala
min hateva, of a transcendental order.
They didn't believe.
Since in Mitzrayim, the Jews were
under transcendental order, all
Yetzias Mitzrayim, this will continue
ad bias hamashiach, ad bias hagoel.
Vayedaber Adoshem el Moshe leimor.
Before he told them about Pesach.
Pesach is the chag lema'ala min hateva.
We celebrate events lema'ala min hateva.
Namely, namely what is
lema'ala min hateva?
...everything in the midbar and everything
about Yetziat Mitzrayim nissim veniflaos!
[Comment from audience] ... everything
I mean, a matter of fact the Chachmei
Yisrael say that the greatest nes
the greatest nes is the man
because it's forty years in succession.
Anyway, but it
cannot go on like that.
Ein somchim al hanes I mean.
Vayedaber Adoshem el Moshe leimor,
daber el Bnei Yisrael ve'amarta
aleihem ki savo'u el ha'aretz asher
ani nosein lachem...That's all.
Uktzartem es ketzirah.
They'll be no man.
No man.
Don't expect that you'll
find man in Eretz Yisrael.
You'll have to plant.
You'll have to to attend to the harvest.
You'll have to reap, I mean the fruit.
Uktzartem es ktzirah.
But ...the order will be
an order, a natural order,
cosmic order.
Adam zoreah bishas zeriah,
veadam kotzer bishaas ktzirah.
There won't be any,
no miracles with man
and no water coming out of
the rock will happen to you.
But now I have to teach you how to live a
natural life in accordance with the Torah.
Before that you are taught how to eat
the Pesach -- mosneichem chagurim,
makelchem beyedchem -- this is
the mitzvos
which were necessary in order to
protect the Jews and to keep him
in a dimension of lema'ala min hateva.
But with the bias
ha'aretz, interesting is, the pasuk in
... says achlu es haman ad boam el ktzei eretz
noshaves and...vayochlu meavur haaretz.
Suddenly the man came to an end.
And with the man coming to an
end, not only the man and other
niflaos came to an end, but the
whole constellation of hashgacha
came to an end.
This is changed from
hashgachas, from hashgacha
lema'ala min hateva into
hashgacha betoch hateva.
And this is uktzartem es ktzirah,
vahaveisem es omer reishis ktzirchem el
hakohein.
But this should not degrade
you this change, this change
should not mislead you.
I'll be with you, with you
and all the promises will be
fulfilled, but in a different way.
Veheinif es haomer lifnei Adoshem
lirtzonchem. When the man was given there
was not...the people had no say how
it should be collected.
Here, after the hashgacha pratis, the
special hashgacha pratis of Mitzrayim came
to an end, in life you will be free to
do many things.
It will be lirtzonchem, mimochoras
haShabbos yenifenu hakohen.
Veasisem beyom hanifchem
es haomer keves ben shnaso.
So is the sefiras haomer and
the korban haomer, the minchas
haomer, are indicative of the tremendous
change which Knesses Yisrael experienced
when they had to change and bizman,
later in the times of Yehoshua, when
they had to change from a nation which
was under the exclusive control of
Hakadosh Baruch Hu and who was, actually
experienced His presence on every step.
And a people come to a land and they
are told to cultivate the land and
to establish a government and to rule
themselves decently in accordance with
laws, with the dinei haTorah, which
are interested mainly in
the hashgacha lemata miderech hateva.
The simple hashgacha, the cosmic order
which was established in Bereishis bara
Elokim es hashamayim ve'es ha'aretz.
This order.
Not the order for nissim
and niflaos exclusively.
In this order is the [inaudible],
and this is the omer, this is the
korban, the korban of, that the
people used to bring erev Pesach.
The first day of Pesach was completely,
completely dedicated, even ledoros,
even nowadays, the first night of
Pesach of Seder is dedicated to what?
what is it dedicated?
Lema'ala miderech hateva.
Matzah, maror, (inaudible).
We do, uveosos uvemofsim, [more
citations from the Haggadah].
And we have a list, we have
a list in the
Dayeinu ... when we say it means
all the nissim which are expressed
in lema'ala miderech hateva.
Expressed in the
list of the nissim which
Hakadosh Baruch Hu did to us.
This is the omer.
This is the korban haomer.
That's why we are not close to Hakadosh
Baruch Hu [inaudible] too close.
We are not
as close as our ancestors whose
story is told in the Bible.
But that's why
we deserve, we deserve chesed, patience
on the part of Hakadosh Baruch Hu.
Because when our ancestors met
Hakadosh Baruch Hu, they were
much closer to him than we are.
They spoke with Hakadosh Baruch
Hu, there was gilui Shechinah
on a personal level, there was
gilui Shechinah on a higher level.
But they had the perception
of Hakadosh Baruch Hu.
We are not as close to
Him as our avoseinu.
But there is something compensating,
namely He is not as swift
and quick with punishment.
Vead yom moso tichakeh lo,
im yashuv miyad tekablo.
Alright.